それが満足と生きるっていうのは
まあ敵同士なんですね
これから話も 日本の社会状況はそれではいる
次にあの仏教的な説明になるんです
だいたいどなたでも満足して生きていきたいでしょ
でも 満足することと生きるっていうことはもう敵同士なんです
もう点的な一致にならないんです
それは論理的にも成り立たないんです
堂々と生きたければ 不満でいなくちゃいけないんです
生きることをやめたければ
満足でいなくちゃいけないんです
これがもう これから説明します
満足するともう大変です
満足したというと その瞬間に喜びがありますね
しかし 満足したならば
その行為を二度とやる必要はなくなるんです
もう十分満足しちゃったら
もうやりたくはないんです
ということは その機能を停止します
満足すると活発性がなくなるんです
すっごく満足しちゃうと
もう機能停止するんですよ
あんまり経験ないんだから
人間にはね だからわからないかもしれませんだけど
例えば もう自分が家の中で
まあもういろいろご飯食べながら
もうゲームやったりして仲間でいると
もう外へ出たくなくなっちゃうし
電話がかけてきても電話にも出たくないし
誰かが話しかけてきてもうるさいと言っちゃうし
今ゲームでもう満足してるんですよ
そこで止まってるんです
だから何か面白くて すごく満足
楽しくて満足っていうことは
その人はそこでカチッと見つけちゃって
もう動かなくなっちゃうんですね
機能停止状態になるんです
ゲームぐらいでは機能していますけど
それっていうのは完璧に満足してないんですよ
本当に満足しちゃうと
カチッと体も心もそこで止めて
もうどうにもならなくなっちゃうんです
もしも人生に生きることに満足したと感じたら
その人には生きることができなくなっていて
人生は終わるんです  人生にはもうものすごく十分満足しました
人っていうことはもう終わっちゃってることになるんですけど
もう何もやることなくなっちゃうんですよ
頑張れなくなっちゃうんです
これっていうのは冗談じゃないんですよ
本当にそうなるんです
もう死ぬんです 満足しちゃうと
成り立ちません 満足と生きるということは
でも 死ぬまでに満足するっていうことはまずありえない
しかし 微妙に我々の生き方
観察してみてください
過去なんかはね 過去を観察できるんですよ
妄想ばっかりしているんだから
もうこのこういうことがありました
こういうことがありましたとか
観察することって大事なんですね
そこでものすごい楽しかった時っていうのは
もう自分が結局は動かないんですよ
他のものに全部興味なくなっちゃうんです
その瞬間 ですから 満足したとは死を意味するのではないでしょうか
満足したっていうことは
本当は死なんですよ しかし
我々の死じゃないんですよ
これはもう突然 もう死んだんです
死んじゃうぐらいもうストップになるんです
私たちは満足して死ぬんじゃなくて
もう死にたくないのに死んじゃうんだから
すごく嫌なんですね それが
ご飯を食べる 仕事をする
学校に行く 掃除 洗濯 料理
買い物をするなどの日々の生き方に決して満足しない
から明日も頑張って生きるんです
こういうこと 何やっても満足しませんよ
だから明日も頑張るんです
満足できんでしょ 掃除したんだからといっても汚れるでしょうに
綺麗じゃないでしょ？一回買い物で一生の食べ物を買うことできないんでしょうに
だから今日買い物に行っても満足して帰ってるわけじゃないんです
例えば安くなんとかなんとか売ってますけど
それ買ってきたって賞味期限なくなるんだから
自分にとってはもうもう結構ですってことになるんですね
だからもう明日も買い物に行かなくちゃいけない
学校に行っても満足できるような勉強しないんだから
明日も学校に行かなくちゃいけない
と 今日ご飯食べても また明日もご飯食べなくちゃいけないんですね
だから満足しないんですよ
満足しないんだから ずっと元気で頑張ってるんです
満足しちゃうと それストップするんです
人間はこれほど努力して
競争して 苦労して生きることに挑戦するエネルギーは不満なんです
人間というのはすっごく明るくて挑戦して生きてるでしょうに
この衝動っていうのは不満なんです
だから 心にあるこの不満が我々を生かしてるんです
お金が足らないというすっごく不満があると頑張るんですよ
じゃあもう今日ではないかと
そういうことでお互い敵同士なんですよ
満足とはありがたいと羨ましく期待するものですが
我々はものすごく満足っていうのは期待してるでしょう
満足になりたいとかね
本当は危ないんですよ
実際満足してみると やる気が失って生きる衝動が消えるんです
ということ それは難しいことじゃないんですよ
普通はもうやっぱりこの人生嫌やと
何やってももうもう切りがなくてもう嫌で
ポッっとしたいんだと
満足したいんだと頭の中で羨ましがってますよ
でも実際に満足しちゃうと大変なことになるんです
では 植物は何のために成長するの？植物の
あの 何といいますか 成長することにゴールって何でしょうかね
なくて あります 花が咲いて実ることなんです
そこであの竹 ものすごい早く成長するでしょ
１週間でもう大体もう １メートルまあげませんだけど
もう 1週間でもう大体もう
いい 三十 四十センチは伸びますよ
みるみるうちに あれぐらい必死で丈が伸びて伸びて大きくなる
何のためかと やっぱり花が咲くためなんです
竹に花が咲いたらどうなりますか
まあね 竹は見たことがないでしょう
それは  全部全部枯れてしまう
えっ 竹やぶ全部が花が咲いて
近くに全部枯れてしまうっていうのを聞いたこと
見たことがあります  そうなんです
全部なくなるんです 普通は竹なんかはめんどくさくてもうもうなかなかもうさっそうとないですよ
もう何やってもどこからでも生えてくるんだから
花が咲いたら一遍にみんなは
だから満足したっていうことは
そういうことと同じなんです
だから何かのために我々生きてるでしょうね
その この その その何かのためって
そこに達したらもうストップになっちゃうんです
ですから 我々日常生活でも満足して作っていると
満足しちゃうんで それでやる気がなくなっちゃう
これからどうしようかと
生きる衝動が消えるんです
不満が生きる衝動なんです
ですから 満足するそう
楽しくなるそう 幸福になるそうという人参を目の前にかけておいて
皆生きているんです だから満足する
幸福になるということは
まあ人参ですね この前にそれぶら下げておくんです
それで生きているんです
もし何万が一 あの人参が口に入っちゃうと
それから進まなくなっちゃうんです
まあ大体人間誰でもね
そんなもんで 我々には満足する
幸福になるという人参が必要なんです
もう咲いている人参をね
目の前で それはもう食べるもんじゃないんです
いつでも前にぶら下がってるんです
これは生きるという法則です
これは法則です 覚えておいてください
生きるということはこういうことですから
不満ですよ 満足っていうのはとんでもない危ないことな
生きることはそこでもう消えてしまう
だから敵同士ですよ もう天敵です
満足で生きるっていうのは天敵と言ったらそういうわけなんです
ちょっと複雑な論理ですけど
この生きる法則 仏教を学ぶということは
ちょこっとレベル高いものを学ばなくちゃいけないんですよ
何でもかんでも漫画レベルで理解できると思ったらね
ちょっと違うんです もうちょこっと難しいことも世の中にあるんです
そういうことで 生きるということと
不満 不満の法則はこれで法則です
覚えておいてください
はい 次に行きます 不満は生かしてくれる神様ですか？と
それだったら まあ次のセクションだから
前理解していないとこちらが進まないんです
私は知ったことじゃない
私はもうスライド 1枚1枚ごとに自分の知識レベルのアップにならないと
もう最後までいけないんです
ですから もう一度練習しましょう
生きるという 元気で明るく生きるためには
すごい不満という衝動が必要なんです
エネルギーが必要なんです
不満というエネルギーがあれば
とにかくやっちゃうんです
もうとにかくもう先に先に頑張って生きてるんです
だから なんで不満で頑張ることで満足になりたいだからなんです
しかし 満足になったら死んじゃうんだから
満足っていうのは 人参のように前にぶら下げておくんです
幸福になりたいとかね
それが生きること それなら我々の苦しんでいるこの不満が神様のようなものではないか
生かしてくれるんだからね
生かされている これとなくなっています
生かされているとよく身を張って言っているのですが
それはわかっているんですか？みんなよく言うでしょ
生かされてますとかね
この間もものすごいもう久しぶりじゃなくて
珍しく 若い人がいて 私は聞いたんですが
生かされているとか何とかとか
よく聞くでしょ どうですかね
本当のところは実感があるのかと
言ったら 何のことはそんな実感ありませんねと言って答えたんです
これは日本人としては珍しい答えなんです
いわゆる正直な本当のこと言わないんだからね
私はすごく あ この人は成長する資格を持っているんだと
それも一般的には生かされている
おかげさまで生きているとかね
まあおかげさまで生きているというのは普通日本語ですからね
それはそんなにいいんだけど
まあ宗教に関係ないんだからね
生かされていると思うと
本当は実感ないんですよ
不満が私たちを生かしているのです
この心に不満ですよ 生かしているのは
ああしなさい こうしなさいと
だから不満の形によって生きてますよ
自分にはどうすることもできないんです
だから我々の生きるパターンを
我々が持っている不満がもう決まっているんです
不満が決めるんです 面白いんですよ
私たちは まあ自分では頭でわかってるでしょ
まあそうすればいいんだけどとかね
頭ではわかってるんだけど
実際はできないんですよ
勉強すればいいとはわかってはいるんだけどというね
で それわかっているっていうのは頭だけのことで
不満を感じていないんですよ
例えばもう学生がいて
もう勉強するのは当たり前なんですけど
まあ勉強すればいいんだけどという場合は
自分が勉強しない自分に対して不満を感じていないんですよ
だから勉強しないで遊ぶことになっちゃうんです
うん 自分でわからないんですね
もうもうもうなんで私が勉強しないで遊ぶことばっかりして
てるんでしょうかとかね
お母さん何とかしてくれとか頼んだりもするんですね
いつでも他人に他人に言うんですね
私はあまり勉強したくないんだけど
どうすればいいのかとかね
夜９時になってくるとすごく眠くなってしまいますけど
どうすればいいんでしょうかとかね
そういう質問ばっかりでしょうね
どうすればいいんですかね
こちらは まあだから それはどうしようもどうすることもできない
人間というのは 自分の持っている不満に合わせて生きているんです
だからどうすればいいじゃなくって
自分の不満というものは何とかしなくちゃいけないんです
不満の形変えたり いろいろ来たりしてね
こんなのは理解もできんでしょうに
だからどうすることもできないんです
この人格変わる 生き方変えるっていうことは
こういう難しい論理を理解しなきゃ
甘くないんですよ 世の中は
自分には発泡スチロール
何て言いますか あれは
あの  発泡スチロール  発泡スチロールで飛行機の形作れますよと
だからってジャンボ機作ってやろうとしても冗談でしょうに
もうジャンボ機作ってもいいんだけど
だったら勉強しなよ 勉強嫌ですよと
工学系の大学に入って入りたくないとかね
そんな話じゃないんですよ
世の中で本当にジャンボ機を作りたければ
それぐらいの勉強して
それぐらいの会社を作って
ものすごくそれぐらい頑張らないとできないんです
発泡スチロールの飛行機だったら
まあもう何も勉強しなくても
カッターだけあればできるんですね
なんでもう飛行機作るよりも宇宙船作るよりも
何よりも大事なのは人生でしょうに
人生の場合はなんとか簡単便利な何かないのかと
というふうに探しますけど
それってすごく無知なんですよ
もうお釈迦様はそれにはもう対応しません
すぐ追い出すんです 他の宗教はもういいよ
この水一滴飲めば必ず天国に行くんだよ
体にこの水をちょこっとかければ
もうあんたはもう全部大丈夫
そんなもんで行ける 天国は
また あれは赤ちゃんが時やりますからね
そいつは知らない それもっといいんですね
自分でも知らないんだけど
ちゃんと判子押してます
これ死んでも体遺体を燃やしても判子あるみたいですけど
あれただの水一滴なんですけど
どう見たっても消えますけど
そうすると水の中に放り込む宗派もあります
洗礼の場合は まあちょこっと中に放り込んで
私にたぶん 1時間ぐらい放り込んでるんですけどね
きちっともう神様のシールを貼っておきましょうと
それで上がるとちゃんとシール貼ってますから
ちょっと入ったらしいです
まあそれは宗派によって変わりますけどね
そんな簡単でしょうかね
人生っていうのは そういう人々であっても
たったあの食パンをトーストにする場合は何分かと気をつけますけどね
だからこの連中は食パン 1枚に対する神経ぐらい自分の人生に使ってないんです
トースターはちょこっとギシッと回したならばちゃんと気をつけるんですよ
あれは 2 分  2 分半で取らないと 10
分ぐらい回しちゃうと
あれはもう焼けまくて燃えますからね
だから人生っていうのは
まあ食パン 1枚ぐらいの価値がないようにね
語る哲学と仏教は極端に違うんです
まあ嫌だったら出て行ってもいいんだけど
仏教はもう結構厳しいことは厳しいです
そういうわけで この不満というものはよく勉強しなくちゃいけない
不満は衝動で 不満が我々のエネルギーで機械なんですね
あの飛行機にもなんかあのエンジンついてるでしょうに
8つとかね  6つとか そういう感じで
自分というものについてるエンジンが不満なんですね
ったっても それはちょこっと誤解するかも
不満というエンジンがついてるんです
そこでもう我々は生きているんです
そこで不満というエンジンがどんな方向へ動くかということによって
人生は変わっていくんですよ
遊び人になるか 安中の人間になるか
すごい知識人になるか
不良者になるか もう何になるかというのは
もう自分の不満というエンジンによって
どうしても遊びたい遊びたいとね
賭け事をしたいとかね
思うとそこら辺で不満を感じて
満足しよう 満足しよう
人参ですからね あれは
だから人参があるところにアシがいるんです
例えば自分が頭が悪くて
まあいや これはと頭いい人間にならなくちゃということは満足ですね
頭が悪いということは不満なんですね
感じちゃう 頭が悪い これダメ
頭のいい人間にならなくちゃと
そこで学問の方に人参が刺さっちゃうでしょう
そこでその人は人参目掛けて学問の道を入るんです
だから 本当に真面目に勉強する人々に
あんたね  1 日ぐらいでもいいんだから遊びましょうと遊びませんよ
あまりにもしつこいと遊ぶところに行くんですよ
行っても面白くないんです
すごくつまらなくて 終わっちゃうんです
それで遊ぶことが人生だと思っている人には
本なんかあげちゃうと全くつまらないんですね
だから その一人一人が自分の不安というエンジンを持って
そのエンジンがここら辺に行きなさい
こういう方向へ走りなさいという風に
方向は決まっています
そういうわけで 神様に生かしているわけじゃないんです
不満が我々を生かしているんです
自分の心にある不満が生命を作り生かす
管理者 神様なんです だから我々の神様っていうのは
我々を作って管理して生かしてあげるのは
私たちの心にある不満というこのエネルギーなんです
だからそれに神様といっても何と言ったっていいんですよ
別にどんな単語でも しかし
この神様を信じる方々にとっては
決して神様を実感できません
信仰するだけ 超越したところにもう存在があって
自分を管理しているんだと信じるだけで
仏教的な説明になってくると
もう神様をすぐじりじりと実感できます
だから自分の不満というのはしっかりと実感できるでしょ
これ実感できると結構その方向転換もできます
神様が会いに待ち 待ちていると
待ちでしたっけ？満ちていると満ちているというから不満に満ち
うん 満たすかね 満たしている我々はなんて幸せ者でしょうかっていうね
だから普通の哲学宗教では神様が愛に満ちていると言ってるでしょうね
我々知ってる神様が不満でしょ
だから不満に満ちて幸せだなとしか言いようがないんです
それは私は言いたいのは
この神様に対する概念が完全に間違っているんですよ
神様は愛に満ちているならば
世の中でこんな不公平あるわけないでしょうに
弱肉強食でいい人はいつでも殺されちゃって
悪人だけ成功して こんな世の中っていうのは
大慈悲の神様を作るはずがないでしょうに
神様はもう今もこのカバンにありますよ
もらったいろいろ紙とかね
神様こそ我々のことを愛してくれるものはいませんとかね
私はものすごく腹が立ちたいと思ったら
これ読むんです 昨日も読んでるんです
誰も周りにいない時は読みますよ
それぐらい愛に満たしますところが
もうどこまで人を馬鹿にしているのかというね
汝のことはもうことことばしてるんだと
自分の唯一の息子まで送ってくれたんだと
あなたの罪のためにと
あなたじゃないんですかね
俺が罪を犯すおべやじゃない
おべはありませんけど
頼んでもないんだよと
イエス様を送って 我は知らんだからね
私の息子がいるっていうことを
だから母親誰ですかね
もちろん母親人間でしょ
どこまで人を馬鹿にしてるんですかね
神の一人息子だったら
そこで作っちゃえばいいでしょうに
他の人間どうやって生まれるんですかね
まあとにかく まあ人間のまあもうお遊びでね
まあ言ってることどうでもいいんですけど
まあ普通言えば神が完全ですごい慈しみを持ってる人であるならば
その神が作ったこの世の中は何やと
一度も一回でも公平なことないでしょう
試しに間違ってでも いい人に限って何か不幸なことがある
悪い人だったらもう何のことなことかね
そこで弱い人は当然殺される
一人一人見ても もう努力しても実るわけじゃないし
まあ大変ですよ だからそれっていうのはあくまでもいい加減なへりくつで知って言ってるわけじゃないんです
我々生かしている世の中は不満だよと言えば全部通りますよ
世の中のこと 不満だからぐちゃぐちゃやってますよ
だから何やってももう結局ろくなことにならないんですよ
だから世の中にあるこのいい加減さ
もうもう何でもかんでもそれで説明できます
当たり前よ 世界は何と言おうとも
北朝鮮はもう何であんただと
我々はもうミサイル作って何が悪いんですかという態度取るんです
イランにしたってもね
イラン 私たちに研究する義務まであなた方はもう禁止するんですか？何者かと
あんた方は イランっていうのは独立している国だよと
誰にもイランにイランの国に命令する権利がないんだと
イランの大統領がいるでしょうに
大統領の大統領いませんからね
だからもう誰が何と言えどもそんな世界でしょうに
だからイランにはイランなりの不満がある
アメリカの大統領様にも勉強できなかったっていう
もうすごい不満がある
それはなんとか暴力で補わなくちゃいけないんだと
だから命令する 命令できるでしょうに
他の国々に 命令聞かなかったら
では暴力で侮辱でやるぞと
そうしちゃうと死ぬのはアメリカ人でしょうに
そのヒーローたちである国のために
なんでそういう風なヘリクツの世界に成り立つかというと
それぞれの方々は心に持っている不満によって生きているんだからなんです
金正日さんなんでしたっけ？その人にしても
もう全部もう自分の国を全部鍵かけてあって
一人ぼっちになっちゃって
まあなんかふざけて遊んでどうですか？どうですかと
そこ外の世界は見ようともしない
外国にも行かない 行ったっても
まあソ連とロシアと中国ぐらいですね
それも隠れて行くんだから
もうまあ国賓なんでしたっけ？そういうすごい堂々と行くわけじゃないんですよね
なんかちょこっと そうすると普通の観光客と同じでね
もっとまあガードするんだからね
それもできなくて それでいろいろ自分も私たちこそあれとか
アメリカはただで済みませんよとかね
なんとか言いながら そちらはそちらの不満の世界を作っている
だから 例えば母親がなんで私は子供にこんなに親切にしてあげているのに
子供はなんでこんな態度するのかと文句を言っても
子供は子供なりの不安を持っていて
不満を持っていて それなりの生き方をする
母親は自分の不満を持っていて
それなりの生き方をする
だからそうなっていますよ
2 たす 2 は 4 というふうにはなりません
母親は愛情いっぱいで子を育てる
結果として子供も母親のことを大事に考えて感謝して立派な大人になると
あり得ません そんなのは
そうありえないんだから
この世の中で神も仏もないんだぞとまた文句を言ってありますよ
もう確かに二人ともいませんだけど
あの 我々の心に不満という創造はあるんです
初めからいないとわかった方がいいのにね
なんか失敗した時だけ神も仏もないというものですからね
私は失敗する以前にいないとわかってますからね
だから自分のことは自分でやる
はい だから不満は神様ではなく鬼なんですよ
結局だから神という言葉でよりもっと合理的に言えば鬼という風にした方がいいのです
満足する瞬間で幸福を感じるんですよ
不満を感じる時 苦しみを味わうんですね
満足は今あるものではなく
理想として探し求めるもの
難しくなるんでしょうかね
まず 1 行  2 行満足すると本当に楽しいんですよ
不満だったら苦しいんです
しかし 不満がないと生きていられません
ということは苦しむ 生きていられません
生きているということは
苦しみを認めるということなんです
満足したら楽しくてたまらないんですよ
しかし 満足っていうのは成り立たないんです
それで我々言ってる満足っていうのは
今あるものじゃなくて
前に説明しましたから
この人参なんですよ ご飯食べて楽しいぞとかね
子供育てて楽しいぞとかね
仕事があって楽しい 冗談でしょ
あれは あれは人参だけ
だからその仕事を家族
子供 子育て 外国旅行 あれこれやとかね
我々は人参をぶら下がってもらってずっと生きているんです
だから理想的なものであって
食べるものじゃないんです
ということで 人生では我々は満足になりたく
幸福になりたく 楽しくなりたく生きているのであって
なるっていう話ではないんです
なった時点でもう生きていられなくなるんです
始めなくなっちゃうんです
不満は常に心にある衝動でしょ
ずっと心の中に不満というのはあるんです
不満は 不安は不安になっちゃったね
苦しみなので これ不満でも不満ですけどね
不満は苦しみなので 生きるということは苦しみに陥ることになるんです
そういうシンプルな論理でしょ
不満があると苦しい しかし
不満がないと生きていられません
私は元気で生きているということは
生きることは苦しいということなんです
これは分離できない現象ですね
生きることと苦しむことも分離できない
不安 不満と生きることの全部ワンセット
これ 満足と生きるということが成り立たないんです
幸福に生きるということは全く非論理的で成り立たないんです
で 仏教を学ばないとそれはわからないんですよ
普通はあれ常識なんですね
幸福に生きるということは
俗世間では でもあれはありえない話なんです
あの空を飛ぶ馬に何て言いますかね
はい ペガサス うん まあ絵は描けますけどね
いるわけないでしょ ペガサスの翼だと思った方がいいんじゃないんですかね
幸福に生きるということは単語はありますよ
ですから 生きるということで
すごい巨大な矛盾が出てきます
明るく元気に生きる 不満の衝動が激しくないとそれはできない
矛盾 明るく元気で生きてましょうと頑張ると
激しい不満でないと生きていられませんね
どちらが明るいんですかね
あんた明るく見えるんだけど
ものすごく落ち着いてないでしょってことでしょ
明るく生きてるようなんですけど
すごく苦しんでるんじゃないのというね
すごい そこで矛盾なんですね
だから矛盾 普通 私は皆様にもあんた方矛盾じゃないかというのは
もうなんかやめなさってるでしょうに
矛盾は この場合はそんな甘くないんですよ
矛盾なんです どうにもならないんです
幸福に生きる それはありえないんですよ
結局はとがありえませんね
これは何でもいいんです
まあかなりもう大胆な言葉たくさん今日は出ています
世の中で言ってることの全くもう違うことを今日はたくさん言葉が出てきますけどね
幸福に生きるということは
まあ成り立たない ペガサスの翼なんです
幸福になって また不満もないなら
生きる力が減退するからです
もし人が幸福になる 不満もなくなった
そういう人 生きる力が減退するんです
だったら幸福に生きるってことできないんです
生きるためにはやっぱり不満というね
エンジンが欲しいんですよ
ですよ エンジンが外しても機械は動くといっても
ありえないんです 不満という苦悩が幸福を作る
不満がなければ幸福もありません
これまたわかりにくい
もうややこしい文章なんですよ
わかりにくいんだけど
これが事実なんですよ
皆様よくわかっているということは嘘なんです
不満という苦悩が幸福を作るんですよ
ずいぶん心配ですよ 例えば
全くのもう食べ物が買うお金もない人がいる
もう家賃も払っていない
もしかすると水道も明日が明日止めるかもしれませんと
もう極端に苦しいです
その人は同時にものすごい不満を持ってるでしょ
そこですぐお金が手に入る
と推測します どうなるんですかね
すっごく楽しいです その人は
家賃も半年間も払ってなくて
もう電気代はもうなくて
もう外の街灯のところでなんとかして
また部屋に入って暗いところで寝ている人が食べるものもなくと
これでいきなりもう 100 万
200 万ぐらい手に入ると
もう信じられないほど幸福を感じるでしょうね
だからそれぐらい幸福を感じるためにすっごい不満が必要なんです
例えば 赤ちゃんのことでものすごく疲れているお母さんが
夜も寝ることもできなくて
誰かさんがもう一人赤ちゃんを連れてきて
この赤ちゃんにはもう面倒見る人はいないんだから
一緒に面倒見てくれませんか？と言って
ああ よかったよかった
二人の子供もらってと思わないでしょ
この一人の子供はどうするのかと
夜ずっと泣いていてとかね
しかし 子供がない苦しみがある
それで子供がもらっちゃうと楽しいんですよ
とっくに赤ちゃんがいるお母さんにとっては
もう一人の赤ちゃんが見たっても自分のものだと思わないし
必要とも思わないんです
なぜならば そのお母さんにはもう不満ないんです
子供がないという不満がないんです
なので 子供が欲しいんだけど
もう子供は産めない 女性がいて
で 親戚の子供は自分でもらっちゃうとものすごく楽しいんです
それで幸福が生まれる
なぜかというと 苦しみがあったんです
叶わない希望があったんです
不満があったんです ですから
それ言ってますよ すごいシンプルに考えてください
ものすごい病気で苦しんでいる時は
お医者さんはありがたく見えるし
すごくお腹が空いている時は
同時に料理料理できる人がいればすごく感謝したくなるし
まあ何でもかんでも我々は持っている不満に合わせたものなんですね
これからもうちょっと読めないんですけど
どうやって読むんですか？と正負を合わせると負は大きいんですよ
大体正は 0 に近いんです
それは仏教の話なんです 0
じゃないんです  0 に近いと
だからまあもう忘れちゃってもいいんです
大体少数点あんまりたくさんになると切っちゃうんでしょ
で 決して仏教はもう生きることはドッカで苦しみであると言ってます
たまたま楽しいことはあるんだけど
なんか 0 に近いんですよ
ちょっとちょっとそれがわかんないですね
ん ちょっと一番下のは理解できない
どこら辺？あ まあこれは負と言ったのは不満なんですね
正と言ったら幸福なんです
だから負と正と書いたのはもうこの上の行の説明なんですね
苦しみが不満がないと幸せがありませんですね
しかし 不満 苦しみが嫌だ
負です 幸福は正です 欲しいんでしょ？だから幸福っていうのは不満が消えることが幸福でしょ
お腹が空くと不満で ご飯食べることは幸福でしょうに
ご飯食べることによってお腹が空いていることは消さなくちゃいけないでしょうに
まあそんなもんで 幸福は正にする
不満は負にする そこで生きる衝動はどうしても不満だから
それは負なんですね それで幸福は正で
だからあなたはどれぐらい幸せになっているのかと計算してみると
もうほとんど0に近いということになるのです
ちょっと余計なことなんですけど
長老のおっしゃりたいことは
あれ 絶対数学で言えば絶対値をつければ理解できますね
うん あの 僕は数学にこだわっちゃってるからこれ理解できないんですけど
あの絶対値っていうのがあるんですよ
あの負の数字も あの負の数字はマイナスついてるけど
その中身がマイナス 10 っていうのと
あの 5 っていうのがあると
5 は正の数なんだけど
マイナス取っちゃうと 10 っていうのは正より大きいわけですね
うん だから絶対値は負の方が大きいですよっていう
そういう意味なのかしらっていうふうに理解したらいいんです
ちょっと余計わかんなくなった
いいです 絶対値をつければ
もうそれで納得いくんですけど
それしか考えられないでしょ
絶対値のことを  それは数式成り立たないでしょ
数学でやったら だから不満が負でしょ
で 要するに幸福が正でしょ
だから負の方が要するに数字が大きいですよっていう
はいはい その通り そっちの方がよくわかりました
私は考えるのは そういう心の気持ちについて
ちょっと例を出したところで
数学を持ってくるというところのこの愚かさなんですよ
すみません  数学は全然こちらで成り立たない話なんです
で これはまあ生きることの論理だからね
もう単純にもうあの日常生活の数学でいいんですよ
私はまあ 1万円借りてますよと
今日は 5万円じゃなくて 5,000円儲かった
そうといえばまた 5,000円借りでしょうに
まあそんな程度でいいんです
別にこれ奉行無用なくてもいいんですけど
我々が感じている苦しみと味わっている幸福っていうのは
あんまり比較したってもほとんどゼロに近いということなんです
それから 不満だからこそ生きることに挑戦するんですね
不満だからこそ生きることに挑戦する
経済 科学発展 学問 文化などがあるんですよ
不満があるだからなんですよ
不満だからこそ 芸術などの遊ぶ
楽しむ文化があるんですよ
不満っていうのは結構もの作りますよ
喜びからすると 憎しみに落ち込むなど生まれるんですね
不満だから 競争する 戦争する
奪い合う それも不満だからこそでしょう
不満だからこうやっています
平和 調和 虐待 いじめ 殺し合いなどもなど何でもあるんです
生きる世界の中に これ全て不満から生まれるものんですよ
不満は基本だから この問題の解決は誰にもできませんね
これでわかるんですよ
世の中っていうのはいろんなものがあるでしょう
良いものも悪いものも
これは良いもの悪いもの
何でもかんでも我々の不満という衝動が作っているんです
だから我々はいじめをやめましょう
虐待をやめましょう どんなこと言っても
どうすればやめられますかね
例えば平和に生きていきましょうと
戦争をやめましょうと言うでしょう
どちらでも不満から出てくるんですよ
不満が出てくると戦争する
戦争しちゃうとまずいから
不満が出てくると平和
平和になる 負けるなぁとわかると
じゃあ平和 平和 平和 え？負けるわけちゃったら戦うさ
そんなもんでしょ だから笑い話ないんですよ
仏教の話は 社会の事実なんです
では 社会から虐待 いじめ
消した人がいる 誰でも
みんなそれ嫌でしょ 学校のいじめなんかはとんでもないこと
でもずっとあったでしょうに
今もあるでしょう これからもあります
どうしようもないんですよ
戦うなよと 喧嘩するなよとよく言ってるでしょう
でもなんで戦うのか 喧嘩するのかというと
不満があるんだからでしょうに
だからまあ その都度その都度戦ったり仲直りしたりとか生きてるんですよ
不満に合わせて 不満によって戦った方がよろしければ戦う
不満によって仲直りした方がよろしければ仲直りする
では 仲直りすることだけ置いておいて
戦うことを社会からもうきれいさっぱりなくそうと思っても
それはもう一般人が言うことであって
仏教ではそれは成り立たないと知っています
ですから 消えないのは不満だけ
元気で努力して生きていると不満が増すんです
普通そうでしょ 頑張れば頑張るほど増すのは不満です
努力しないで落ち込むと怠けると不満が増すんです
どうすればいいんですかね
頑張れば頑張るほど 仕事に挑戦すればするほど不満が増すんです
では 何もしないで怠けてやると言っちゃうと
むちゃくちゃ不満が出てくるんです
成功するとより成功したくなる
不満がさらに増えたということです
いわゆる書きたかったのは
成功すると不満が増すということなんです
わからないんだから 一応中だけ書いたんです
成功しても不満が増します
ですから 逆に言えば失敗すると不安が増します
成功すると不満が増して
失敗すると不安が増す
努力すると不安が増して
怠けると不安が増す というわけで
あまり文学的に書く暇がないんだから
一応カットしましたけど
不満が限りなく生まれていくんです
不満というのはいくらでも生まれて生まれていくんです
これまたちょこっと同じ
不満に対する挑戦は生きることです
ちょこちょこって この数学入れちゃうとまたまずいことになりますけど
私は数学できなくて良かったと思いますね
なぜ仏教のこういうことは見事に簡単に理解しますからね
皆さんはね この箱でモノでなければ理解しないでしょ
そんなものは存在しないんです
ものっていうのはね 次に来ます
そこら辺 だから結局は超越した知恵としか言えない
こっちはいくらもちょこっと単純に考えてください
仕事をしても不安が生じる
しなくても不安だけ 不満だけは出てくる
頑張ったら不満が現れていくのは
頑張らなかったらまた不満になっちゃう
成功しちゃうととことん不満になっちゃうし
失敗するとまたとことん不満になる
いくらでも不満が生まれてくる
その不満を潰すことが生きることなんです
不満を潰すと何か生まれますかね？不満が生まれる
そこでもう数学ではその説明できないんですよ
科学の世界 科学的に 論理学的に言えば
成功すると不満がなくならならば
失敗すると不満が現れるということになります
そんなのはもう世の中の物質論の考え方で
存在論ではなくなっちゃうんです
存在実際はそうじゃないんです
成功するともっと成功しなくちゃいけないんでしょうに
すごい厳しいでしょうね
なんかちょこちょこっと成功したのはいいんだけど
次にもっと成功しなさいと言うとできるわけないでしょうに
えらい不満になるんです
これは成功する人々はよくわかると思いますよ
何か成功すると次にまあもっとすごい世界が現れてくる
そこで成功しなくちゃいけない
失敗すると同じことだ
だから成功しても不安が増して
失敗しても不安が増す
それで不安だから生きているんですよ
だから何やっても生まれてくるのは不安なんだ
不満なんです それは数学でどう書けばいいんですかね
数学成り立ちません そこでもうやっぱり存在として考えてみてください
次の行は次に出しますけど
私は   生きれば生きるほど何が大きくなるんですか？不満が大きくなるんですよ
不満が大きくなればなるほど
生きることに挑戦するでしょう
ということで 無限ということになるんです
終わらないということが起きたんです
消えませんと ずっとみんな私に説明してくれと言っているのは
この輪廻転生 どうなるのか
本当にあるのかとか 科学ではそんなのはわかりませんって
何考えてるんですかね
科学 数学っていうのは一個も成り立たない
ものすごい乗り越えている世界ですからね
これを理解してみてください
輪廻転生というのは当たり前の話なんです
不満に挑戦しないバカがいませんよ
不満だから呼吸したり
生きて全部やってますよ
何やっても増えるのは不満なんですよ
そうするとまた挑戦するんです
しなくちゃあかんのです
ということで 生きるということは
切って終わりということは成り立たないです
それが仏教では輪廻なんです
これは理解してください
もう二度と輪廻転生はどうなるのかと質問しないでください
これはすごい難しいんです
魂もないのに どうやって私は生まれ変わるんでしょうか？とか
何考えてるんでしょうか
と こっちは魂論は全然成り立ってないんで
まあとにかくこの まあひとで考えればわかることでね
まあ座りで考える余裕がないかもしれませんだけど
ここでちょっと休みに入ります
消えないのは不満だけ
人は良いことばかりして生きていても
悪いことばかりして生きていても
善も悪もして生きていても
単純に収入を得て生きることだけをしても
生きることは嫌で 何もしないでいても
不満があるから生き続けるしかありません
これ 何やっても不満が生まれてくるんですよ
だから生き続けるということはもう避けられない
はめられています 何やっても
必ず輪廻転生するんです
どうしようもないんです
苦が無限に続くんです
その意味は だから不満論の面白いところはそういうことなんですよ
私は良いことをするぞと思ったら
ものすごいもう不満が
エネルギーがあるんだからこうやっています
悪いことする人も不満があるんだから悪いことをする
まあそんなことはなく
ただ食べ物がある場合だと
仕事をして食べて寝て
それで人生終わる人もいる
それでも不満だからなんです
何もしないでいる人に対しても
またどんどん不満が生じてくる
不満が生じると戦うんです
幸福という人間が戦う
それが生きるということなんです
だからどこまででもこのシステム
は続くようになっているのです
良い不満 悪い不満というのはいうふうに考えた方がいいわけですか？ それは考えません
成功すればより成功したいとなりますよね
その時に欲で考える場合と
向上心というですか もっとより良い成功を収めたいというふうに考える場合は
どっちも不満ですよね
だから善的な不満と悪
善悪にした方がいいんですね
こっちはそこを一応ざらざらと
結局はね 人を助けるのも不満だから
人を殴るのも不満だからなんですよ
一つは良い不満で 一つは悪い不満で
一つの不満は善行になるし
一つの不満は悪行為になる
だから仏教から言えば
あなたはいいことをしたっても
悪いことしたっても 輪廻からは逃げられ
逃げられませんと だから仏教
本当に仏教の難しいところになってくると
善も悪も否定するんです
どちらでも不満から生まれますから
捨てるということになります
普通の一般仏教になってくると
悪いことをしてはいけません
いっぱい良いことをしましょう
それで幸せに生きてましょうっていうのは
それはまあ子供向きの仏教で
本物の仏教になってくると
これは不満でやることだから
輪廻が続くだけですよ
というわけで ちょこっと題が変わりましたから
ちょっと休憩いたします
では 次のセクション始まります
これからもっと難しくなります
今までの仏教の話でしたけど
まあそれはまだ普通な
もっと難しいことはなりますけど
うん